tu as fait quoi comme opération toi
parce que là ça se voit pas du tout hein
il y a deux jours enfin je l'ai fait en
trois jours
je retrouve mon visage je me retrouve en
fait alors raconte nous qu'est-ce que tu
avais fait alors moi c'est vrai que j'ai
fait ma première télé
j'ai fait les Marseillais et c'est vrai
que de base je n'ai pas de complexe
voilà je n'avais jamais fait de
chirurgie et une fois mon portrait
dévoilé sur les réseaux sociaux
forcément on regarde un petit peu les
commentaires et dans les commentaires
voilà il y avait beaucoup de mauvais
commentaires disant que j'étais moche
que je ressemble à un homme que j'étais
pas belle on faisait des comparaisons
entre les différentes filles dans la
télé etc et c'est vrai que de base
j'avais pas forcément de complexe et en
voyant tous ces commentaires bon tu les
as dans la tête mais bon ça passe et
ensuite
tu te vois donc à la télé je te vois sur
différentes prises de vue que tu ne
verrais pas dans la vie de tous les
jours donc tu vois que ton nez est un
petit peu plus gros
voilà donc là tu te dis bon la prochaine
télé bon je me fais peut-être je me
refais un petit peu le nez pour voir sur
la prochaine télé si ça va mieux si je
passe à l'écran non juste j'ai fait de
la médecine esthétique c'est différent
de la chirurgie esthétique médecine
esthétique c'est d'acide hyaluronique
entre 6 à 12 mois
et après tu as lancé un mec qui revient
on a un client après des 6 mois une fois
si ça touche moi tout simplement
ils vont regrossir vous allez voir alors
tu as fait tu as fait quoi d'autre et
ensuite je suis allée chez un docteur à
Paris donc de base c'était pour refaire
ma bouche et au final ce docteur il me
dit bon il y a tes cernes qu'elles sont
un peu creuses tu pourrais en faire un
petit peu là tu pourras un peu faire ici
dans le nez dans le menton et moi c'est
vrai que de base j'étais pas je suis pas
allé forcément pour ça et au final ben
je me suis un petit peu fait influencer
et du coup bah m'a fait un petit peu
dans le cerne tout ça après tu en as
fait dans les cernes dans le nez dans le
menton et dans la bouche
et forcément il y a l'urine dass c'est
une enzyme pour dégonfler l'acide
hyaluronique on attend notre visage et
de chacun
je peux te dire tu es très belle
[Musique]
avant après avant après avant après
voilà
avant avant
en fait vu qu'on m'a rajouté de l'acide
hyaluronique forcément je me dis que ça
faisait
bah oui mais là pour le coup en fait
l'arrête de son nez elle est toute fine
là vous avez vu
ton effet il est moins bien là comme il
est plus faim il fait plus long oui
exactement mais c'est même pas ça c'est
qu'en fait ils ont migré et en fait j'ai
des visages bouffi voilà c'est un truc
de fou et je me reconnaissais plus dans
le miroir et en fait je me rendais pas
compte parce que pour moi les injections
ça permet de t'embellir et en fait un
jour j'ai eu des clics grâce à mes
proches qui me suivent de très près ils
m'ont dit Laura c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible ma mère qui
m'a fait qui m'a conçu à une dit Laura
ton visage il a complètement changé et
j'ai eu un déclic en fait j'ai eu un
déclic heureusement parce qu'il y a
certaines filles qui n'ont pas déclic et
qui continuent dans l'excès moi
justement j'ai eu ce déclic et du coup
j'ai décidé le lendemain je faisais des
en fait je m'étais des photos avant
après et je regardais la différence
j'arrivais pas à voir et enfin si
j'arrive à avoir mais j'étais dans le
déni total et du coup bah j'ai fait donc
la technique alors une date qui
heureusement existe parce qu'avant il
fallait attendre en fait que l'acide
part de lui-même alors il y en a pas mal
de comme toi on va revenir sur ton câble
qui regrette aussi la chirurgie
esthétique c'est Sacha Buisses par
exemple un ex-candidat télé-réalité
Secret Story 8 s'est confié concernant
ses nombreux opérations il a avoué les
regretter regardez
me dit pourquoi j'ai fait tout ça j'ai
un implant fissuré j'ai deux vaisseaux
sanguins tout bleu en dessous de mon
maquillage c'est pour ça que j'ai
demandé qu'on me maquille beaucoup les
cernes aujourd'hui j'ai une bouche qui
fait un peu canard alors que j'avais une
belle bouche juste parce que j'ai écouté
un conseil je ne suis pas ce que je peux
refléter je suis quelqu'un de très
simple dans le fond c'est vrai qu'avec
la maturité et tout je réfléchirai à
deux fois et j'aurai un autre message à
faire passer donc c'est vrai que c'est
c'est alors il y a aussi Benoît Dubois
chroniqueur sur l'excellente émission
TPMP people expertisement Secret Story
c'est également confié sur ces
opérations chirurgiques c'est qui qui
l'a même avoué qu'il trouvait certaines
de ces opérations ridicules c'est au
micro de l'animateur numéro 2 de la
chaîne
de luxe vous avez fait quoi donc vous
avez fait le nez on répète bien tout ce
que vous devenez 4500 le sexe 3500 le
sexe c'était une Pénoplastie durant un
an et demi je le déconseille fortement
ah oui bah parce que ça dure pas c'est
très cher ça dure pas c'est ridicule ça
dure un an et demi ça a coûté 3500 euros
pour vous faire grandir le sexe de
combien de centimètres en diamètre en
longueur c'est le diamètre qui
m'intéresse c'est moi le plus important
si on le déconseillé parce que ça tient
pas je le déconseille parce que c'est un
c'est esthétique ça marche pas à
l'érection enfin c'est vraiment j'ai
fait ça j'avais 22 ans j'avais de la
thune je partais à Barcelone ça m'a
amusé
on a la réponse
vous verrez Cyril ça tient un an un an
et demi à peu près et puis ça tient
jusqu'au 8 mars
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qui regardent il y en a une autre qui
n'existe pas à parler des sensibilisés
concernant la chirurgie esthétique c'est
met la night la candidate de
télé-réalité c'est même fait enlever ses
injections elle aussi et c'est vrai que
je sais pas comment ça se passe pour
enlever les injections on fait comment
en fait alors en fait c'est la technique
qui hyaluronidas tout simplement en fait
il vous mette un produit ok naturel pour
qui détruit en fait l'acide hyaluronique
ça fait mal ça fait très très très mal
parce qu'en fait c'est pour vous donner
une idée c'est comme si on vous en fait
déjà quand on vous fait des injections
on vous met du produit là en fait On
vous retire le produit donc en fait
c'est on vous aspire comme si on vous
suggérer le sang quoi
c'est comme une comme un suçon quoi non
mais il y a un truc aussi que les jeunes
font beaucoup maintenant parce que c'est
moins cher dans d'autres pays c'est les
dents et j'aimerais vraiment leur dire
que les dents c'est vraiment la
personnalité de quelqu'un c'est c'est
ils ont tous des espèces de piano tout
droit comme ça c'est des facettes c'est
horrible et à partir de 45 ans
à une poupée Barbie je suis désolé c'est
plus que je veux être c'est plus que je
veux faire et surtout c'est démodé le
produit miracle pour être à nouveau dans
la tendance s'appelle le hyaluronidas
c'est une molécule qui va aller
dissoudre la situation
les microboules de dacylorique qui sont
dans la lèvre cette intervention coûte
autant qu'une injection soit 350 euros
mais contrairement à cette dernière il
n'y a pas d'effet immédiat le résultat
ne sera définitif que dans une semaine
j'ai envie de modérer parce que moi j'ai
fait plusieurs opérations moi j'ai fait
les cheveux j'ai fait les paupières et
j'ai fait les cernes voilà et j'en ai
une liposuccion et j'ai regretté aucune
des opérations à ce que le problème
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup ça va bien j'ai
rien fait aucune des opération et les
cheveux aussi j'avais une tête il suffit
de regarder les premières de TPMP
j'avais une tête horrible
malheureusement c'est devenu quelque
chose de très tendance il y a autant de
chirurgiens que de de complexe et il y
en a des chirurgences
après souvent le problème aussi c'est
que sur les réseaux parfois quand ils
montent les photos par exemple pour
enfin des bouches que les docteurs font
souvent c'est retoucher aussi c'est pas
forcément vrai ça reflète pas vraiment
ce qu'on va avoir comme résultat quand
c'est les filtres aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux qui sont responsables de ça je
vous l'avais montré la dernière fois une
jeune femme à Inès qui montre une photo
d'elle avec un filtre à son chirurgien
lui dit je veux ça regardez dès qu'elle
se filme ou se prend en photo elle
utilise une application qui retouche son
visage cette beauté virtuelle Inès fait
tout pour l'atteindre dans la vraie vie
et pour cela elle a recours à un autre
subterfuge est-ce que le résultat au
niveau du nez est-ce qu'on pourrait
avoir ça ou pas
[Musique]
[Rires]
est-ce que maintenant parce que vous
avez eu aussi des commentaires qui vous
ont poursuivi chaque fois que vous
faites quelque chose est-ce que
maintenant vous arrivez à vous détacher
de ça ou est-ce que ça vous fait
toujours aussi mal alors
voilà on dit toujours qu'on regarde pas
trop les commentaires etc mais au bout
d'un moment en fait ça rentre dans la
tête au début on regarde pas on calcule
pas le trop mais au bout d'un moment
quand on vous dit oui tu es moche oui ça
oui tu devrais faire si ça ça bah ça
rentre dans la tête et forcément bah tu
le fais et mais moi maintenant oui enfin
la vie le plus important c'est de mes
proches en fait c'est pas de ce qui est
virtuel parce que ça ne veut rien dire
en fait c'est vrai que c'était gonflé
c'était gonflé
[Musique]
en fait au départ je me trouvais belle
merci au début je me trouvais entre
guillemets belle parce que je me disais
les injections ça permet d'embellir donc
mais après en fait j'étais je me rends
compte que j'étais dans le déni et un
jour je me suis réveillé j'ai dit non
mais Laura c'est pas toi même les
anciennes personnes qui me connaissaient
ma mère elle reconnaissait plus Laura
on se disputer parce qu'elle me disait
Laura
elle me disait Laura ton visage a changé
et moi je disais mais non maman enfin je
me suis embellie ça ça me rend plus
belle en fait les mamans ont toujours
raison qui disaient les garçons mine de
rien
au final mais maintenant que j'ai enlevé
ils me disent en fait
ça fait que deux jours vraiment que j'ai
retrouvé
tout de suite
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes sur les réseaux vous êtes
filmés en train de faire des opérations
et maintenant vous avez tout fait vous
filmez en train de retirer ce que vous
avez fait une façon d'entretien le buzz
un peu comme filmé à ce moment d'être
filmé vous êtes filmés en train de vous
faire retirer vos implants favor
silicone
dans le milieu de TPMP une question la
Daniel Moreau Michel
[Rires]
c'est les pédopsychiatres la première
source de dépression c'est Instagram
c'est ce qu'ils disent tous parce
qu'aujourd'hui un autre époque je fais
les vieux cons mais on se comparait pas
on se regardait pas avec d'autres
maintenant ils se compare
systématiquement vous n'avez que des
bombes que des mêmes top Golay des
filles magnifiques en ce moment j'arrête
pas de me comparer à qui c'est vrai
j'arrête pas de me comparer
moi ça m'arrive en regardant Instagram
tu regardes tu as que des mecs des
bombes des bombes des bombes
tu es toujours sur mon compte
elle elle doit recommencer en fait tous
les ans son acide hyaluronique c'est
tous les ans cette affaire vous allez
vous dire recommencer sinon le ça tout
retombe en fait en fait ça part au bout
entre 6 à 12 mois voilà ça reste pas
toute la vie c'est de la médecine
esthétique la chirurgie esthétique c'est
ça reste toute la vie on va dire
regardez
une simple seringue remplie d'acide
hyaluronique se fit l'acide hyaluronique
est une substance déjà présente dans
notre peau et qui possède un très fort
pouvoir hydratant l'intervention ne dure
que quelques minutes et le résultat est
immédiat mais comme l'acide hyaluronique
se résorbe avec le temps les faits n'est
pas permanent si elle veut conserver son
nouveau-né Inès devra refaire des
injections tous les ans
elle a été ratée on peut le dire vous
êtes magnifique est-ce que vous avez
porté plainte et est-ce que vous avez
envie que celui qui vous a fait ça ça
sanctionner
oui c'est lui il veut toujours des sons
oui enfin non j'ai j'ai pas j'ai pas
pensé à porter plainte
enfin je veux pas me mettre dans des
histoires tout ça mais en tout cas
aujourd'hui ce que je peux dire c'est
que il faut vraiment faire il faut pas
en faire en fait on est belle naturelle
on n'a pas besoin de ça on est jeune au
final comme enfin on revient toujours à
la maison au final j'ai fait tout ça
pour au final
j'adore oui et en revanche vous avez
pointé du doigt quelque chose qui m'a
choqué dans votre discours vous avez dit
que vous y alliez pour une opération une
seule chose et que le c'est le médecin
lui-même qui vous a dit vous devriez
faire si vous devriez
le médecin n'aurait pas eu de passage
sachant que si on est influençable et
qu'on a un petit peu faible au final et
là on est plus dans la médecine
commerciale
merci merci
Laura d'avoir été avec nous